so you probably heard congress passing a
900 billion
relief deal after negotiations uh
finally uh
got on track and they signed something
they agreed to something
it was supposed to be targeted direct
aid for restaurants it was supposed to
be in the deal but it's not in the deal
at least 110 000 restaurants closed
permanently since march
while 2.1 million restaurant workers
lost their jobs
our next guest owned six restaurants two
bars before his pandemic
and has since had to close two of his
restaurants and one of his bars
he is uh here now his restaurant tour
himself robert st
john robert what were you hoping was in
the 900 billion dollar deal
and what's in it that will help you
well uh i'm talking to you from
hattiesburg mississippi and our senator
senator roger wicker took the lead on
this thing back in may and introduced
the restaurants act
um congressman blumenhauer in the house
introduced the
house version it passed the senate
version had 53
people on on both sides of the aisle
when you got chuck schumer on one side
and lindsey graham on the other side
we had dick durbin john cornyn 53
senators signed on
but we uh we we didn't get it in this
new legislation so we're holding out a
little hope uh that when
congress comes back this next congress
in january
uh the reference act will be a part of
that because
what people don't understand i think
brian is uh
independent restaurants uh there are 500
000
independent restaurants in america we're
the number two industry right behind
healthcare
you've got 11 million people who work in
independent restaurants but there are
also 5 million people
in ancillary businesses like farmers
fishermen and people like that
that that are just i mean desperate
right now it's it's
it's rough out here so and i agree with
you 100
robert so this thing happens it hits in
the uh in the winter
they tell you to suck it up to the
spring and what did you do in order to
reopen give us an idea
of the investments you put in to be
responsible
uh bar slash restaurant owner yeah so
uh my first restaurant that i opened was
in 1987. that's kind of our flagship
restaurant and in march
we served our last meal before the
shutdown not knowing it would be the
last meal we ever served
the business model there just uh wasn't
going to work going forward so as you
said
you know we had six restaurants two bars
we're sitting here with
four restaurants and one bar uh hanging
on
right now but you know everybody is in
different states
i'm i'm talking to you from our kind of
breakfast uh community cafe
um and you know it it closed four months
and other restaurants were shut down for
a few weeks
i have friends in colorado who did great
during the summer when you had outdoor
dining but right now it's snowing there
so it's different all over the country
but
i think uh restaurant tours we aren't
really used to asking for help and we're
a little ill-equipped to do that we're
in a brutal business
we have low margins you know we deal
with a lot of controversy already
but but we we aren't used to asking for
help and
you know 2008 came and went in the
financial crisis you didn't hear a word
from us i live
about an hour north of the gulf of
mexico there were six hurricanes
that came through the area of this year
and we just kind of when that happens we
hitch up our britches and
and get back to work but but this is
this is unbelievable robert
what the numbers the numbers do not say
that you guys are a super spreader
most people are spreading this in their
homes what is your message to lawmakers
who keep shutting you down and limiting
your capacity
well my message would be sign the
restaurants act
when january comes around signed the
independent restaurant coalition which
is a group i'm a part of that just
formed in march
uh took the lead on that and worked with
senator wicker in the senate
they need to pass that i saw the study
you're talking about in new york that
was from september to november and like
74
of the spread came from households yeah
and uh
and gathering events and 1.4
came from restaurants and bars and so
you know
we're used to dealing with the health
department we're used to health issues
when
when it came time to put on masks and
put on gloves and have sanitizer
we deal with that kind of thing all the
time
it's unbelievable i just think that if
some of these politicians worked in the
restaurant business
they understand what you guys do on a
regular basis
because you have the free market if
you're not
safe if it is not clean if it is not a
place
you will go out of business all you want
is the opportunity
to be successful and these politicians
have robbed you of that
because they say would they want to they
want to look
out for you and to me that is so
insulting
yeah brian uh 20 of the jobs already
lost
in this pandemic of all jobs came came
straight out of
the food and beverage business and it's
estimated that 85
may close permanently and we're talking
about small bit i'm not talking about
franchise restaurants or big
change or anything like that i'm talking
about mom and pop restaurants
independent businesses like the one i
started i was 26 years old
when i started this thing and worked 90
hours a week for the first four years in
a hot kitchen and loved it and i love
this business and and i'm going to stay
in this business you got people
all over the country just like this that
are just fighting to survive right now
and even we're great at it it is so
intense it brings that family atmosphere
because you got to turn the tables over
you got to seat the people you got to
clean up
and at the end of the night you're
exhausted and usually go out and get a
drink together after
and that's why it's so hard for an owner
like you to tell workers
i can't pay you more they close me up
it's like family uh more than almost any
other business
that i was able to work in robert st
john can't thank you enough for joining
us
and uh hopefully this restaurant act
we'll keep talking about it and we'll
get it past this
in 2021